Bình bị ngày 1,5 tốc không thể thông qua dữ lực nơi xác tạm thời giao hà viện trình lên,
đánh giao lần thức bại thử 1,5 tốc.
Cú thể dữ lực nơi xác tạm thời đến ngày 2,5 tốc.
Một gió hà viện để trình lên này, chỉ nhận được 50 tư kêu thật.
Không buồn sống hiểu cần thiết theo cuy đình để được thông qua.
Để chính phủ Mỹ bất sàng ngày thứ 7,5 cho tình trạm đồng cửa,
mong với kỳ lục dài nhất từng kỳ nhận hồi quễ năm 20,5 đồng năm 20,5 chín.
Dởi những kỳ đầu của tổng thông trăm.
Tình trạm đồng cửa giao dài đang gây đình trẻ hàng loạt lím cụ tự hạn không,
tì tế đến an sinh giả hội.
Văn phòng nên xác của hội cạnh báo,
nếu bế tắt giao dài thêm tạm tôn,
nếu kinh tế của tế kể thải tới 1 tí đô.
Quảng 4,5 chụng mời hưởng chậm tức phẩm s拿b bị cắt giảm,
hồn công trong khi nhìn biệt lên băng,
tư kạng sát, anixen bay,
kìm sát không liều đến quần đôi, vẫn phải là việc dế ám lực cao mặt không được chả lương.
Lãnh đào phê cộng hoàn tròn thương,
cảo vúc phay dân chủ,
cố tình, cảo dài bế tắt,
cộn lãnh đào phay dân chủ chắc xù mời nói,
chuyên sách của đàn cộng hoàn phíang giả mạo hiểm y tế tăng cao,
an hưởng tới 2,5 chụng mời trong một đàn kì mời.
Tổng thông thông thông thông gương nàn trăm kêu gọi,
bại bỏ quy định sống mới phíau tại thương viện để thông quảng nhanh sách.
Càng báo nếu không là vầy đàn cộng hoàn sế phay chả giả trong bầu cử giữa kì.
Cảo cao xác xác hội mời được công bố,
chỉ mởi loch cần trăm lý dân Mỹ,
hai loch mời cách của hội xử li của hạ nghiệm này.